today of course is Super Tuesday the
biggest day in the race for the
Democratic nomination so far voters from
14 states are heading to the polls to
help award more than 1300 delegates the
biggest prizes are California and Texas
which award nearly half of today's
delegates last night Joe Biden made his
final pitch to voters with a rally in
Dallas coming off of a reenergize in
victory in South Carolina Biden as you
may have heard was endorsed by former
candidates Pete Lou de jedge better or
wolf and Amy Klobuchar who just dropped
out a few hours earlier Amy is in our
green room she'll be up soon Omar
Villafranca was at the rally and is at a
polling station in Dallas this morning
Omar what's it like there right now well
right now Gail one good morning the
polling place is open there's already a
line but you see around me sign signs
everywhere the signs 228 delegates up
for grabs but let's get to the important
thing some of the numbers in the latest
CBS News battleground tracker poll from
Texas that shows Bernie Sanders with a
four point lead over George Joe Biden
now it's important to note that the poll
was taken before Pete Budaj and Amy
Klobuchar dropped out so it remains to
be seen where their voters are gonna go
now former candidates Buddah chechik
globe Klobuchar and Bethel work tried to
make sure that the support goes to Biden
when they endorsed him last night in
Dallas I actually talked to some
Democratic voters who were there they
feel Biden is more moderate they liked
that and can possibly even win some
Republican voters in the general
election and I had a few tell me that
they feel that Sanders is too liberal
for them as Texas Democrats now one
interesting aspect from our latest poll
56% of likely Democratic primary voters
here in Texas say they have a favorable
view of socialism and that's gonna bode
well for Bernie Sanders he describes
himself as a Democratic Socialist now
today will also be a good indicator of
the effectiveness of Mike Bloomberg
strategy of skipping those early
contests and focusing on Super Tuesday
it's the first time he's been on any
ballot he's been spending millions of
dollars blitzing the airwaves buying
billboards he spent more than 47 million
dollars here in Texas alone another big
thing to keep an eye out
the Hispanic vote about 40% of the
electorate just here in Texas and based
on the CBS News polling some of the
voters are telling us that they feel
Sanders deals better with the Hispanic
issue but we're gonna have to wait and
see Anthony all right Omar thank you
you